hi it's Kevin Van Ord here standing in
for reviewer Josiah renauldi to tell you
about madden 15 madden 15 corrects the
series troubled course by taking two big
steps in the right direction
number one revamp defensive play gives
you a reason to actively participate as
you defend a drive number to precise
attention to detail returns the sense of
awe that had gone missing deficiencies
in the passing game and technical
hiccups still proved distracting but
Madden 15s missteps do little to detract
from an otherwise strong outing
[Applause]
controlling the defenses felt like an
afterthought in recent years since your
actions as an active defender rarely
made an impact on the progression of the
play but madden 15 focuses on making it
fun to play both sides of the ball
favorable matchups allow you to slink
past the offense and once you've broken
through you're able to see you're
tackling range the safest route is to
use the more reserved tackle which
almost guarantees an easy sack but you
can also make use of the less accurate
hit stick if you're feeling lucky
systems that were once fairly automated
now require your undivided attention
giving you more reasons to stay engaged
in all four quarters of a game the
running game made considerable strides
last year and only feels sharper this
time around breaking tackles and
trucking past defenders looks and feels
great and you can feel the different
attributes of each player as soon as the
ball is snapped pass plays on the other
hand can lead to some frustrations you
have a great deal of finesse with the
ball when taking control of a
quarterback and receivers make more
creative catches than ever before
but interceptions happen still too often
and even the strongest receivers just
don't do enough to battle for the ball
play now an online head-to-head modes
are there for the exploring and they're
the best way to go if you just want to
get on the field but connected
franchise' is a feature attraction and
it's been given a bit of a facelift this
year here you choose between becoming a
player coach or owner of your favorite
franchise which gives you the power to
either affect the flow of individual
games or get involved in the team's
upkeep the newest additions are a game
prep feature and a statistic for
individual player confidence game prep
provides different activities that give
you more experience while confidence
takes into account the ups and downs
even veterans feel from week to week
however some of the game prep drills
involve nothing more than selecting a
player and immediately earning the
additional points without even running a
play meanwhile and madden ultimate team
you create your fantasy team by opening
booster packs bought with either in-game
money or real cash Solo challenges earn
you coins and unlock full games with the
possibility of earning even more money
and the streamlined interface makes it
easier than ever to slot in your best
players however the pacing of
progression is too slow if you're
unwilling to whip out your wallet just
throwing down a couple of bucks to
expedite the process is tempting turning
what could be Madden's best mode into a
sort of microtransaction scheme but even
if you never go beyond the play now mode
the mechanical improvements on offense
and defense make Madden 15 well worth a
look this is the best playing football
game and unsurprisingly it's also the
best-looking one the feature set remains
mostly unchanged but each core mode has
increased in breadth and decreased in
clutter Madden 15 looks the part of a
next-generation showpiece but its
biggest achievement is its dedication to
improving core systems that have held
the series back in
fast
[Applause]
[Music]